what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we even start this video I'm
going to tell you guys this video has
spoilers so if you don't like spoilers
don't watch this video having said that
in age of Ultron as we know the vision
wields Thor's hammer and so the question
that you guys have been bombarding me
with is Rob who can wield Thor's hammer
what's the deal with this make it make
sense and so because I'm coming
explained and because my goal is to make
sure you guys understand what in the
world is going on in Marvel Comics and
all the intricacies and all I kind of
good stuff we're going to be covering
that and so what we're going to do in
this video is we're going to go over a
list for taining to both DC and Marvel
characters but we're going to be leaving
out the Asgardian so now keep in mind
some of these characters are able to
wield Thor's hammer because in Thor's
earlier continuity that he was separated
from his hammer for more than 60 seconds
he lost his powers and he basically
transformed into his human form of
Donald Blake now in addition to this not
all of the Marvel characters that wield
Thor's hammer in the mainstream
continuity are able to do this within
the mainstream continuity proper it is
to say some of the characters like Black
Widow for example wield Thor's hammer
during the age of Ultron what if
alternate story which of course is a
character I guess an event that we'll
talk about here but starting with Marvel
Comics the first person on our list is
none other than beta ray bill now beta
ray bill has a special place in the
hearts and minds of Thor fans everywhere
because beta ray bill was the first
person to be able to wield Thor's hammer
now this comes about and Thor vol 1
issue number 337 when we learn that beta
ray bill is a cyborg and that he was
designed by the korbinites in order to
safeguard them as they were leaving
their planet which had already been
destroyed and traveling to a new planet
and so what happened is that along the
way they passed by the planet Earth and
when they did shield registered their
convoy of sorts and they sent Thor to
investigate and so when Thor arrives to
basically examine the convoy
way that the the ship of beta ray bill
which is actually called scuttlebutt
British first Thor as a possible threat
and so because of this it activates beta
ray bill and beta ray bill and for end
up getting into a fight now while
they're fighting one another one is up
happening here is that the Thor is
separated from his hammer for sixty
Seconds and the result is that he
basically reverts back to his human form
at which point beta ray bill knocks him
unconscious and so when beta ray bill
sees the hammer of Thor fall he examines
it and out of curiosity picks it up and
when he does he's endowed with the power
of four and so odd and realizing what's
going on here takes beta ray bill and
Thor away and then has them basically
duel to a battle to the death but
partway through this battle
Odin begins to realize the worthiness of
a beta ray bill and so what he does is
he gives beta ray bill a version of
Mjolnir of the hammer of Thor in the
sense that is called Stormbreaker what
this hammer is is basically an exact
copy of Thor's hammer the difference
here is that this hammer was designed
specifically for beta ray bill and this
is the reason why so many fans love the
character of beta ray bill he was the
first person to be able to wield Thor's
hammer outside of the Asgardians
themselves now the next person on our
list is Captain America now Captain
America wields Thor's hammer for the
first time in 1988 and Thor vol 1 issue
number 390 now what we find is that in
this story during a confrontation with a
minor villain named grog who only
appeared in about 15 comics or so that
Thor and Captain America are basically
ambushed and so the result is that
during the fight Thor is separated from
his hammer and that basically Captain
America in an act of desperation picks
the hammer up and then throws it to
those two Thor now of course during this
time Captain America uses the hammer to
beat up a couple villains and so on but
nonetheless this was the very first time
we ever actually saw this happen now a
lot of Marvel comic fans really knew
this time was coming they knew that at
some point along the line of Captain
America's continuity he was going to
pick up for his hammer but this was a
really cool instance and this is the
reason why for a lot of you guys who saw
the age of Ultron trailer when capture
America had budgeted the hammer of Thor
that Marvel comics fans flipped because
they thought this was going to be the
time when we finally get to see Captain
America pick up Thor's hammer and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe now the next
person on our list comes in the form of
rogue now again Row is a character who
picks up Thor's hammer but not in the
mainstream continuity rogue picks up
Thor's hammer during a what-if storyline
which actually came in what if volume 2
issue number 66 with the title what if
rogue had the power of four then what
happens here is this story largely ties
into the very early days of rogue in the
sense that when rogue first appeared in
Marvel Comics she was basically
operating with mystique as a daughter of
mystique and trying to earn mystique
respect and so in order to do this what
she does is she house mystique break the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants out of out
of prison but what ends up happening
here is that they're immediately
confronted by the Avengers and when this
happens
rogue seizes Thor and when she does she
basically absorbs the power of four into
herself and when she absorbs the thought
of the power 4 into herself she's able
to wield Thor's hammer proper now
eventually what happens here like many
of the characters whose powers are I
guess mines rogue is absorbed we find
that Thor's Cod is this sort of rises to
the surface and so what takes place here
is that rogue is ultimately I guess
she'll totally comes under the control
or I guess maybe steps into the role of
floor proper and becomes that universe
is that alternate realities version of
Thor now the next person to wield Thor's
hammer is Black Widow and again much
like a rogue story this is an alternate
universe what this does is it gives us
an alternate reality to the age of
Ultron event rather than the mainstream
age of Ultron event that we had seen in
this story what ends up happening is
that for ends up dying as a result of
the Ragnarok event and of course again
if you're curious about Ragnarok I have
a video explaining what that is but what
is up happening here is that because
Thor is dead as hammer simply left
behind and so with Thor's hammer being
left behind what we find is that Black
Widow effectively picks it up and when
she does she ultimately steps into the
role of Thor and basically brings an end
to the Ragnarok event ultimately
defeating the Great Serpent that was
supposed to arise with Ragnarok and then
eventually becomes that
student realities version of for now
from here what we're going to do is
we're going to transition away from
Marvel characters and we're going to
step into DC characters and so I imagine
a lot of you guys are really curious to
see where we're going to go with this
when we get into the DC characters what
we actually do here is we pick up with
the Marvel vs. DC event and this was
basically a story whereby we saw in 1996
that Marvel characters and DC characters
had come together and basically fought
one another and so with issue number two
along with several other several other
fights what we found was that Marvel had
basically I guess Marvel and DC had
basically reached out to fans and said
you guys decide who it is that ends up
winning this fight with issue number two
what we found was a conflict between
Wonder Woman and storm but what takes
place here is that during a battle with
Shazam Thor is separated from his hammer
and what he separated from his hammer
Wonder Woman comes upon his hammer and
after reading the inscription about
whoever's worthy can pick up this hammer
she picks it up and when she does she's
endowed with the outfit of Thor as well
as the powers of Thor and she uses these
abilities to basically fight against
storm now from here we jump to the final
person and our lists of people who have
been able to wield Thor's hammer and
this person comes in the form of none
other than Superman you guys had to know
Superman was going to be on our list
there's no way he couldn't be now this
took place during the Justice League of
America and Avengers crossover in 2004
now again much like Marvel vs. DC this
was a crossover whereby the superheroes
had initially fought against one another
but the result is that the Justice
League of America and the Avengers band
together to fight against all of their
respective supervillains and so what
happens is that during this conflict
Thor is beginning to become overwhelmed
and so what he does is he actually
throws his hammer to Superman in the
hopes that Superman will be able to
stave off the I guess the convergence of
both of these universes and what
Superman does while he's wielding the
hammer of four and has the shield of
Captain America is he unleashes holy
hell it's one of them it's one of the
most impressive things that I've ever
seen in the history of comic book
publications it's pretty amazing but
again this is really just sort of a fan
thing a lot of fans really just wanted
to see what would happen if Superman
were able to wield the hammer of Thor
now again this isn't necessarily canon
in the sense that because it's not part
of the mainstream continuity a lot of
people don't consider it to be absolute
but for the sake of our list we're going
to go ahead and throw it in here because
why not because awesome so with that
being said I'm gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end and let me know let
me know down in the comments either fun
let me know in the comments section if
you can think of one person that can
wield Thor's hammer who would that
person be anyway I'm curious to see what
you guys say I think they'd be kind of
cool but I'm gonna go ahead and get out
of here and I will catch you guys later
peace
Oh
ah